Since you're enrolled
in this course,
let's assume that you have
decided on, or perhaps are
already engaged in, a managerial
or professional career.
And that you are
developing, or have already
developed the knowledge and
skills necessary to do the job.
That's great, but
don't stop there.
Experts agree that it will take
a special set of competencies
to succeed in tomorrow's
organizations, which
will be even more globalized,
digitized, collaborative,
and agile than
those we see today.
Many have written on this topic.
One of the best
sources, we think,
is a small monograph published
by the Institute of the Future,
titled, The Future
of Work Skills 2020.
Here is a brief synopsis
of the 10 competencies
that the Institute suggests will
be essential for your career
success and the years ahead.
First, relating
to globalization.
The Institute stresses the need
for cross-cultural competency,
which has a couple
of key components.
One is the ability
to work effectively
with those from other
cultures, perhaps
in teams made up of many
different nationalities.
And the other is the ability
to work effectively outside
of your native land.
And while most
business probably will
continue to be
conducted in English,
it certainly wouldn't
hurt to have a familiarity
with other languages as well.
Turning to the circle
label digitisation,
we see that there are four
key competencies involved.
One is sense-making.
The future will be
all about mass data.
We will be even more
inundated than we are now,
so it will be necessary
to have the capacity
to work through
tons of information
and see the big picture.
We'll have to be
critical thinkers.
But we also have to keep
in mind that technology
isn't good for everything.
So we need to
develop the capacity
to decide when to
rely on computers
for assistance and answers, and
just as important, when not to.
A second competency in this
area is computational thinking.
This includes developing
a basic understanding
of computer programming
and simulation modeling.
It doesn't mean that we all
have to become computer geeks.
In the era of big data, We can
rely on specially trained data
scientists to do
the heavy lifting.
But the rest of us
will need to know
enough about what
the experts are
doing to be actively involved
in the process in two ways.
One is on the front end, to
frame questions and problems
in ways that the data
scientists can analyze a model.
And two, on the back
end, to be the ones who
interpret the results
and come up with value
added answers and solutions.
Third, in this context,
there is the issue
of new media literacy.
Here the reference
is to becoming expert
in the use of
social media tools:
internets, blogs, podcasts,
videos, and so forth.
In the future, many folks
will be working remotely
and will be called upon to
create and share content
through these
technologies, and to do so
in ways that not only help
solve complex problems,
but also engage and
persuade our colleagues
and other important people,
such as customers and clients.
Finally in this area is
cognitive load management.
In tomorrow's world,
it will be very
easy to get overwhelmed by
the mass of information that's
bound to come our way.
We need to learn
how to avoid this.
How to evaluate,
rank, and tag content
so that we keep our eyes
on what's really important
and let the rest go.
Somewhat ironically,
computer programs
are already available
to help with this.
They have the
ability to sense when
we are becoming
overloaded or tired,
and then, to
automatically intervene,
to slow down or simplify
the flow of information
we're getting.
Third, let's turn to the
issue of collaboration.
One essential competency
here is social intelligence.
This refers to the
ability to connect
with others in an emotional
and deeply personal way
to quickly assess the
feelings of others
and then adapt our words,
tone, and gestures accordingly.
Everyone agrees that this is a
uniquely human competency that
so far, at least, gives
us a leg up on robots.
Further, the Institute talks
about virtual collaboration,
meaning the ability
to work effectively
with, and eventually, perhaps,
lead teammates we may never
meet or even see in person.
This involves becoming
really good at turning
in-house networks and
new media into what
some call social water coolers.
Important tools helping to
enhance a sense of camaraderie
and social presence
among colleagues
who are all over the map.
Online gamers already have
a leg up on developing
this competency, since
this is, in large part,
what they are learning to do.
And finally, let's
consider agility,
which really is the capacity
to be comfortable with change.
Three competencies
are stressed here.
One is novel and
adaptive thinking.
In a world of rapid
change, it is essential
that we never let
the tried and true
get in the way of being open
to new ways of doing things.
In the future, all of
us will be expected
to keep our eyes on developments
that are going on in the world
so that we can anticipate
upcoming challenges.
And most important,
be on the leading edge
of developing unique and
creative ideas and solutions
to deal with these
challenges in real time.
Second, the Institute
talks about design mindset.
This is closely related to
novel and adaptive thinking.
It refers to being super
familiar with our work
situation, so that we can see
when changes need to be made.
But even more
important, it refers
to having the ability to
make useful recommendations
for redesigning the
work environment
as well as the processes
and procedures being
used to get the work done.
And then, there is
what the Institute
calls transdisciplinarity,
which is
a big word for a simple idea.
In the future, the idea
worker will be t-shaped.
That is, deeply expert in one
or more disciplines, which
is the vertical part of the T,
but also knowledgeable about
and comfortable with
many other disciplines,
the horizontal part of
the T. In other words,
once your world
class one thing, make
sure you keep right on learning
about a lot of other things.
Success in the future will
depend on our willingness
and ability to keep
growing and developing
to become more global
in our thinking,
more comfortable with the
digitisation of everything,
ever better it collaborating
with colleagues and others,
and above all, staying deeply
committed to being adaptive,
lifelong learners.